Gregg Doyle here from the indie star in
the Rich Eisen show how are you Greg
that is so nice of your wrist thank you
very much I'm gonna make a fool of
myself at times but it's always going to
be a fool coming from the heart as
opposed to josh mcdaniels who who like
like many invertebrates operates in a
cold-blooded way and I'm not sure he
even has a heart No yes real quick no I
don't care I love Mike Reiss
I love Mike Reiss but I do not care what
sources or McDaniels or anybody says
about his kids in school and all that
how about the kids of the coaches that
he hired for the Colts and those guys
are here right now in Indianapolis to
work for Josh McDaniels only he's not
coming
how about their kids is it true that he
didn't tell them he's not coming what
are you hearing on that Dianna rossini
ESPN started you know a competitor but
she's really good she tweeted that she
talked to people involved you know those
are those people and they hadn't heard
from Josh yet and this is like three
hours after the news broke so I believe
that and first of all or finally you you
have to look at well who is josh
mcdaniels is he the kind of guy that
would do something as despicable as that
I submit what happened yesterday and I
rest my case
oh I submit what happened in Denver and
rest my case he's a little nitwit so
Greg what why did the cult's ago in his
direction in the first place they
screwed up and I've you know and not to
be that guy but I wrote that three weeks
ago so it's easy to come on here today
and say oh they screwed up they
shouldn't if I was on that three weeks
ago and you know blind squirrel found or
not whatever but I hated that three
weeks ago I think Chris Ballard's great
I really do I'm not a but kiss her at
all because the the most important thing
he's never done is hire josh mcdaniels
and the moment he did it I pulled out my
unit and peed on it so I'm not gonna
like always take Chris Ballard is
perfect but I think he's very very good
and he just screwed up with Josh
McDaniels I really can't explain how he
could do something that dumb because I
really believe in him but that was dumb
well so let's take this one step at a
time Greg Doyle of the Indianapolis Star
here on the atashi show so first steps
go back to my UNIX I kind of like that
no I think we were just gonna leave that
wherever that is
so in terms of of Irsay he had to sign
off on all of this right I mean so and
the question is is why we're going to
the Belichick family tree knowing all
the history between the Colts and the
Belichick family tree listen you're
preaching to the choir when you ask that
question and I don't understand I don't
I don't get it I mean nothing about
behind three weeks ago made sense and
and for three weeks I honestly felt like
the one guy trying to tell everybody the
world really is round people you you can
keep on sailing in the ocean you're not
gonna fall off the edge of the earth
people women tell me that the world is
flat Josh McDaniels a great hire and
that's what the cult obviously thought I
don't know I don't know how they could
possibly have done that it makes no
sense to me
three weeks ago it makes no sense to me
today and if anybody ever hires him
again besides the Patriots and I'm sure
they will I'm sure that's part of the
promises that you will replace balichek
if anybody ever hires him again I'm
laughing at them in the in advance but
also what I'm going to love is that he's
going to take over the Patriots
obviously peltex gonna be gone and Brad
you'll be gone because bail checks not
leaving with milk in that utter he's not
leaving Brady he's gonna stay with Brady
so good luck McDaniel's I wish you and
your two and fourteen career well so
what can you tell me about Andrew Luck
shoulder from what you're hearing there
Greg
terrifying terrifying you know I hear
this from a lot of folks because folks
hear what they want to hear and then
Chris Ballard he's so good when he talks
you know some people when they talk it's
just well Ben McAdoo has no presence at
all I mean none some guys have so much
presence that you're just blown away and
you believe everything they say Matt
Ballard is can be that guy and he tried
to say today that and your luck is fine
but if you take away the bells and
whistles of his delivery and listen to
the facts the facts of these Andrew Luck
was shut down four months ago
four months ago shut down from throwing
footballs he was told football's again
shut down and in four months
including time spent in the netting
Netherlands doing whatever he was doing
over there four months later he doesn't
pick two football up again in four
months that's terrifying
so beyond that though I mean to answer
question do I have any idea
like am i am i saying he's never a
plague no I have no idea but neither the
Colts I mean if you can't pick up a
football for months after being shut
down the first time I mean for months
rich I'm gonna saying for weeks for
months for months after surgery drew
Brees is picking up football Angela I
can't pick up a football for months
after being shot down which was nine
months after surgery this is scary stuff
Greg Doyle the Indianapolis Star here on
the Rich Eisen show so do you trust
Ballard to do the right thing it was a
nice red meat performance today I
thought he did a very good job even
dropped the rivalry is back on as he
walked away from the podium if I'm a
Colts fan I am I really enjoyed seeing
his classy but still very pissed off
demeanor today Greg he's great I'm
telling you that I've been do this for a
long time and you have to I know there's
there's a handful of guys that you walk
with a press conference going that guy's
so incredibly good I can't believe it
Calipari is on that list Mike chefs is
on that list I'm putting Chris pound on
that list I mean he's just so good it
doesn't mean he's always right I mean
people can be great with their
delivering just be wrong and I'm not I
don't trust I do trust Ballard but I
will say it's been shaken I mean it's
been shaken in a yes-no world are the
Colts in good hands about yes or no yes
they are am i as convinced of this as I
was five weeks ago no I'm not a scratch
the poll question even though I probably
know what the answer is but it'll be
interesting anyway go for it Chris Brock
me yeah Greg would you rather be the
Patriots offensive coordinator and maybe
the head coach and waiting or the Colts
head coach with a very questionable and
rueake quarterback well to be listen
you're asking me this question right yes
sir
to be the Patriots on this coordinator
means I'm living with those people up
there so no I'd rather be I'd rather be
the Colts I'd rather be the let's see
the tape on in the locker room that
players step on with our cleats
I'd rather be that tape than live in New
England with some of the people that I
hear from on a daily basis
and I also want to hit this too because
I found it interesting and also
respectable and commendable from Ballard
that he mentioned the names of Jeffrey
Monroe and Edwin Jackson before he
mentioned josh mcdaniels today and
that's the uber driver of Edwin Jackson
and they both perished in a car accident
with a suspected drunken driver Greg can
you tell people who might not know who
had when Jackson was who he was and what
he didn't I mean he was inside my back
to the Colts but I know what you mean he
he was a great guy he was a sweetheart I
mean he was and there aren't many
sweethearts and NFL locker rooms there's
no work and this is how sweet that kid
was he I mean fortunately what occurred
in high school walk on to Jordan's other
one wasn't drafted walked on to the NFL
then he goes to his first ever job
interview goes to trial for the
Cardinals and I'm not sure why but he
missed his flight so he took a second
flight got the Phoenix and it was so
mortified by missing his flight and
being late and so terrified that he's
blown his chance and such a sweet kid
that he thought it would help if he
brought his mom's homemade pound cake
and gave it to the coaches so as they
made this pound cake that's who he was
and that's it wasn't locker room here
with the Colts always smiling just the I
mean we always say this about guys that
died too soon but you couldn't you
couldn't say it about anybody mean it
more than you about Evan Jackson and so
I did love that Ballard yes said his
name but also said Monroe's name's uber
driver because unlike a lot of folks in
this country and by that I mean
politicians who are name-dropping Edwin
Jackson as if they would pee on NFL play
if they were on fire and they wouldn't
but now it when Jackson as a hero Donald
Trump because he's a brick in the wall
he wants to build Mexico to keep those
little aliens out because the driver
who's drunk was allegedly in a little
alien so whatever I thought Ballard
thank you for mentioning Monroe because
to me that's very important because his
life matters as much as Evan Jackson and
Jackson was a sweetheart in hearsays
paying for both funerals correct yes
what are say does or say you ever say
one time used his private look he's got
flaws I get it and if you want me to run
a long term paper on all of Jerry's
flaws it'd be a long one he's got him
but he's also kind of guy that when a
guy a stranger lost his dog and his dog
was found like a thousand miles away her
sights in his private jet and took the
dog to him he just has a huge heart Greg
the call man will chat again real soon
and I'm that that was some high quality
sports writin look I mean I read it and
you know obviously you used words that
usually aren't seen in a in a any sports
column but it felt like you meant it you
know it's a bad rap sometimes your anger
is legit and sincere and deserved I
think in this case it was but your tweet
last night when you you that meant a lot
to me and what you said to me here a few
minutes ago min a lot thank you you got
a Greg thanks to the call Mike gets greg
doyle of the Indianapolis Star a Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience